[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to "Deconstructing Chatbots."
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and today's episode
is a special one
because we are going
to visit Spring ML's office
in Pleasanton, California
and sit down with Dhruv Hemmady,
their expert at managing
conversational AI projects.
Stay tuned because we will
talk about real-world use
cases of conversational
AI, how some of them
have come to life,
starting from the idea
to the finished experience.
Without further delay, let's
go and chat with Dhruv.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DHRUV HEMMADY: My
name's Dhruv Hemmady.
I'm a technical project
manager at Spring ML.
Spring ML is a
Google Cloud Premier
Partner in advanced analytics
and machine learning.
We work on AI and ML use
cases across computer vision,
chatbots, predictive modeling,
increasingly data migration
as well.
We founded the company
about four years ago now--
started as a small local team
of less than 10 employees.
We've grown
exponentially since then.
We're about 100 folks
all over the globe--
four different offices.
And it's been an
exciting journey.
We feel like we're just getting
started in a lot of ways.
So the founders started
with a core belief
that machine learning and
artificial intelligence
will really transform the
way enterprises do business
in the future.
And that's really our mission
is to help them incorporate AI
and ML across their business.
Google is probably the
leader in AI and ML,
and we've leveraged a lot of
the best Google technologies,
from TensorFlow to
AutoML to Dialogflow
for building chatbots, and
really helped customers
accelerate the time
that they see impact.
We've seen use cases, both B2B
as well as consumer chatbots,
spanning a number of different
industries, from retail
to banking to pharmaceutical.
One that we did recently
for a big pharma company--
helping their product
managers easily
retrieve information about
different drug studies
as well as regulatory hurdles.
We also worked on a cool
consumer bot for a retailer
in helping them provide a gift
recommender for the customers.
I think the biggest
learning, as I see it,
is that design is
fundamental to building
any successful chatbot.
Unlike traditional
IVR systems, chatbots
can handle non-linear
conversations.
And so really working
with business stakeholders
to figure out what the ideal
conversation flow looks like
will be essential to
building that bot that
works for the users.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Thanks,
Dhruv, for having me
here today, at Spring
ML office in Pleasanton.
It's such a nice day today.
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely.
Really nice.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So what do
you mean by conversation flow?
How do you design
a conversation?
DHRUV HEMMADY: We ask a
number of different questions
initially, right off the bat.
First, we want to understand
what are the key business
objectives of the chatbot.
What is your workflow like?
Will a human be
part of the process,
or should the bot be able
to handle all questions?
Then we move to some more
tactical types of things.
So how many unique
types of questions
do you want the bot to handle?
Are most of those
questions static?
Is there a general
response for a question,
or are they dynamic questions?
So is it dependent on
the specific information
that the user provides?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So like connecting
to a back-end
database or something.
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Once you
have kicked off a project,
what do you see as some of the
implementation recommendations
that you provide to users?
DHRUV HEMMADY: So if
you're a new customer,
we recommend that you start with
a four-week POC just to kind
of showcase the art
of what is possible--
maybe throw in some static
and dynamic questions
for some variety.
We start with a week of
requirement gathering,
followed by a couple weeks
of agile development.
We'll take your
feedback into account.
And finally, a week
of user acceptance
testing, just to make sure
that users are comfortable,
and everything is
working effectively.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: What happens
after maybe a month or so?
DHRUV HEMMADY: Sure,
so after about a month,
that's when we move
into a production phase.
So that'll be a
couple more months
where we add more questions,
both static and dynamic.
We may add a user
interface, and then
we may release the bot
through multiple channels,
including Google
Assistant and Google Home,
but others like Facebook
Messenger and Slack.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
Dhruv, you've talked about,
a little bit, in terms of how
to implement the chatbots.
You've talked about
some examples.
Can you show me a
back-end infrastructure,
an architecture, of an
implemented chatbot?
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely,
let me show you.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
All right.
We are with Dhruv,
and he's going
to walk us through how some
of these chatbots work.
DHRUV HEMMADY: Yeah, so
let's take a look at one
that we did for a coffee shop.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Ooh, coffee.
I love coffee.
Can we get donuts too?
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely.
That's what the chatbot
will do for you.
So this chatbot basically
helps the coffee shop automate
their customer service.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Awesome.
DHRUV HEMMADY: So
as you can see,
we have aggregated some
of the most popular items
at the bottom here, just to
allow users to easily select
one of the items.
So for example, if you want
to order a couple donuts,
you can select the
item at the bottom.
And as you can see
to the right, we're
basically showing you
your order in real time,
so you can see how
much you're paying.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And the front end,
is it created with App Engine?
DHRUV HEMMADY: It is, yes.
So this is deployed
on App Engine.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
DHRUV HEMMADY: And one other
item that's kind of cool
is you can select what's
most popular this week.
So for that, we're able
to aggregate overall data
over the past week
and figure out
what was the most ordered item.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Oh, that is amazing.
DHRUV HEMMADY: Would
you be interested to see
what that was?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Sure.
DHRUV HEMMADY: OK.
So we click on that.
Oh, wow.
It looks like some
more glazed donuts.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
[LAUGHS] I think
I've had enough for today.
DHRUV HEMMADY: Enough for today?
OK.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So that-- actually,
the coffee shop
demo itself was pretty
enlightening to understand
how the front end would work.
Can you show me an
example which talks
about a little bit of back
end, behind the scenes stuff?
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely.
So we actually did
a chatbot recently
for a Google internal team--
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Perfect.
DHRUV HEMMADY: --for
Google Collections.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
DHRUV HEMMADY: And really,
what this chatbot does is it
helps Google customers
easily look up their account
information, invoice
details, details
about their account in general.
For example, if you're
a customer at Telemart,
you can easily look up
information specific
to Telemart, and
only once you're
authenticated as a
Telemart costumer.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
So what does the front end
look like for that one?
DHRUV HEMMADY: So for that
one, we go to the bot.
So as you can see, this is
a main Google Help page.
And to the bottom
left, we have a section
for Google Collections.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
DHRUV HEMMADY: So you
can click on that,
and then you have to log
in with your details.
And again, only if you're
a Telemart customer are
you authenticated to
see Telemart invoices.
So in this case, we'll
use those email details.
And now we're on the main
Google Collections page.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And I see the
chat window that can come up.
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely.
So it's a pop-up at
the bottom right.
So if you click
on the pop-up, you
can now start using the chatbot.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, perfect.
So before we actually start to
use the chatbot with Telemart
as an example, can
you show some of
the back-end interconnections
between the Dialogflow
interface and the
front end and what's
in the behind the scenes?
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely.
So basically, users are
interacting with the web
UI deployed on App Engine.
Now that App Engine layer
sits on top of Dialogflow.
And Dialogflow is where
all of the user questions
are built in.
Now, Dialogflow integrates
to a couple of applications.
It integrates to BigQuery.
In this case, BigQuery is where
all of our data is stored,
all the information around
account details and invoices.
And then the actual
documents themselves--
they're stored in Cloud Storage.
And what that does
is basically allows
us to email those
documents back to the user
after they ask questions.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
So are you going to
show the example where
we see the email coming out?
DHRUV HEMMADY: Absolutely.
Let's take a look.
Say I wanted to find
my latest invoices--
so it asked for
our company name.
So we're at Telemart.
Then as you can see,
the chatbot responds
with the three latest
unpaid invoices,
so the invoice numbers, the due
date, as well as the amounts.
And then if you
go to your email,
you can see that
those just arrived.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Oh, great.
DHRUV HEMMADY: You can
take a look at the copies.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That is perfect.
Can we also look at
Dialogflow interface
and some of the intents
that were created in there?
DHRUV HEMMADY: Yes, absolutely.
So as you can see,
each of these items
here are different intents.
So on that latest invoices
example, if you click on it--
so we fed in some
different training phrases.
So those are different
ways that a user
can ask a particular question--
you know, recent invoice,
latest unpaid invoices.
And as I mentioned before, the
cool thing about Dialogflow
is that it has the ML and AI
capability to learn over time.
So if you ask something similar,
it should know that that's--
latest invoices is what,
in fact, you're asking for.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, awesome.
That was great.
Thank you so much for giving
us all that information,
starting from how you
started to design the bot,
up to the point
where how you created
these integrations with
BigQuery as well as with GCS.
Thanks, Dhruv, for walking
us through that amazing demo.
DHRUV HEMMADY:
You're very welcome.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, I
hope you enjoyed the tips
and tricks shared
by Dhruv today,
to bring your conversational
AI use case to life.
We cannot wait to hear more
about your specific use case
in the comments below.
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]